เฮ
[Música]
Boa noite a todos. É um prazer estar
aqui com
vocês. Vamos discutir um pouquinho sobre
o assunto da MPOX que vocês pediram no
grupo. Não estou acompanhando muitas
mensagens, mas a última mensagem que eu
vi que vocês queriam que eu falasse de
MIPOX e dos casos que tiveram
recentemente. Boa noite, Antônio. Me
diga se o áudio tá legal. Eu tô
usando um fone novo da Apple que eu
comprei na viagem, eh, que ele é
portátil, né?
Me diga se o som tá saindo legal, tá,
Antônio? E quem fori entrando também se
manifeste, diga se tá tudo bem. Sandra,
boa noite. Obrigado tá presente na live.
Antônio dizendo que está
OK. Sandra, por favor, também diga se
você escuta bem. Ok. Bem, eu não sei se
vocês estão tão interessados no assunto
da da Mipox, mas me pareceu que era o
caso, tá? Vamos começar com esse
assunto, depois a gente vai paraas
dúvidas.
Então vamos abordar de uma maneira
detalhada a situação atual da MPOX no
estado do Pará. Vamos analisar aqui
dados oficiais, dados e casos
confirmados, aspectos clínicos e
controvérsias em torno das soluções
aí imunológicas disponíveis, né? Então
essa apresentação foi preparada com base
nas informações que eu pude apurar mais
recentes sobre esse assunto e que foram
disponibilizadas aí pelas autoridades
sanitárias e também na
internet. Então temos a seguinte
situação. No estado do Pará foram
documentados 19 casos desde o início de
2025 até 23 de abril e esses casos estão
distribuídos em regiões geográficas de
Belém. da capital do
estado, que registrou a maioria dos
casos, né, dos 19, registrou 14.
E a segunda localidade registrada foi a
Nanindeua, né, que é uma cidade menor lá
do
estado. Teve três casos em Anindua, um
caso em Marituba e outro caso em portado
de outro
estado. E apesar desses números, as
autoridades sanitárias mantém que não há
situação de surto na
região. Então esse padrão de
distribuição ele sugere uma concentração
urbana, particularmente na área
metropolitana de Belém, que responde por
95% dos casos. E essa concentração pode
refletir tanto fatores de densidade
populacional quanto potencialmente
sistemas de vigilância mais robustos que
estão captando os casos, né? Então pode
ser tanto
que tá relacionada à densidade
populacional, que nós sabemos que faz
sentido, quanto que é a região que tem
mais eh notificações. Então isso pode
estar também, de certa forma tá
distorcendo um pouco os dados, OK? Que
áreas rurais a notificação é bem menor.
Então não foram registrados duas mortes
entre esses
casos, ambos indivíduos falecidos.
tinham comorbidades, tá? Isso aumentou o
risco de doença grave. Então isso que a
gente discutiu em momentos anteriores,
em lives anteriores, né, que a mipoxia é
um problema para quem tem comorbidades e
não é uma doença grave em pessoas de boa
saúde, tá?
Então, as autoridades sanitárias
enfatizaram que essas fatalidades
ocorreram em pacientes com condições de
saúde subjacentes, né, como eu
expliquei, sugerindo que o risco real e
geral de
mortalidade permanece relativamente
baixo para indivíduos
saudáveis. Temos aqui um caso que ficou
famoso de uma pessoa notável aí da
região, que é o guto xibatada, né? Essa
morte ganhou a atenção pública porque
foi de um cantor local de forró, né, que
tem uma fama local. Chama-se Augusto
Demétrio Neto, também conhecido como
Guto Shibatada, tinha 39 anos, né? chama
atenção à idade, né, desse
rapaz e teria contraído o vírus no final
de 2024 durante uma viagem, mas
inicialmente não foi revelado a condição
de saúde para os
familiares. Então, segundo o secretário
municipal de saúde de Belém, que é o
Rômulina, a morte do chibatada em 23 de
abril de 2025 resultou de complicações
respiratórias associadas a outras
doenças, não diretamente a MIPOX. Então
esse caso trouxe maior conscientização
sobre a doença na região, porque ele era
uma pessoa famosa, obviamente, embora as
autoridades mantenham que foi um caso
isolado e não tem evidências de surto
pelo número de casos, realmente a gente
não pode falar em surto, né, que foram
pouco mais aí de 20 casos.
Então, o cantor havia sido hospitalizado
no pronto socorro Mário Pinote em Belém,
após apresentar convulsões e febre e
antes da hospitalização ele estava
recebendo tratamento em isolamento do
homiciliar, conforme foi recomendado. E
vamos falar então sobre a resposta
oficial ao caso e à
declarações. Então, em 28 de abril de
2025, a Secretaria de Estado, a
Secretaria de Estado de Saúde do Pará, o
CESPA e a Secretaria Municipal de Saúde
de Belém, que é o Sesma, realizaram uma
coletiva de imprensa para abordar
preocupações públicas sobre o potencial
surto dessa doença do Mipox. Então,
durante esse evento, o secretário Romina
declarou de forma explícita que estariam
fora de um surto, fora de qualquer
hipótese dessa categoria.
As autoridades sanitárias
enfatizaram que todos os casos
confirmados estão sendo monitorados por
equipes de saúde, que não teria
indicação de agravamento da doença em
nível
populacional. Essa resposta demonstra
uma tentativa de manter a calma enquanto
se reconhece a presença da doença na
região. Então, a situação está sendo
ativamente monitorada dentro da
estrutura de vigilância nacional. O
Ministério da Saúde implementou um plano
de contingência para responder o Ipox
com estágios operacionais definidos com
base na situação epidemiológica. Então,
com base nos atuais números de casos
registrados e padrões de transmissão, o
Pará parece estar classificado em status
não emergencial. Então, pelo número de
casos, eu concordo com isso.
OK? Então, vamos falar de novo sobre
MPOX. Nós falamos sobre isso ano
passado, sobre mecanismos de
transmissão, características clínicas.
Então, MPOX ele é causado pel vírus que
é da família da varíula, é o vírus
Monkeyippox, que mais tecnicamente
falando pertence à família Ortopox
Vírus. É um dos maiores e mais
resistentes vírus de DNA conhecidos. E a
doença pode se espalhar por várias vias,
por contato corpo a corpo, né? Contato
próximo ou íntimo entre indivíduos
infectados, particularmente através de
contato direto pele à pele, através de
contato com a erupção cutânea ou crostas
na doença, contato com fluidos
corporais, que pode ser saliva, fêmeas,
secreções
respiratórias e o contato sexual. OK?
E se fala muito também de contato
homossexual, apesar que não ser
exclusivo por essa via, né? E também tem
contato com objetos contaminados,
incluindo roupas, roupas de cama,
toalha, utensílio, prato, itens pessoais
de forma geral. E existe também uma
transmissão entre animal e humano, que é
a chamada zoonótica, né?
Zoonoses, particularmente em regiões
endêmicas. Então, existe sim isso na
África Ocidental e Central, que pessoas
têm contatos com animais infectados, ou
pode acontecer através de mordidas ou
arranhões desses
animais. No Brasil, não é uma forma de
transmissão que esteja sendo
divulgada. Então, o Ministério da Saúde
observa que a transmissão do vírus tem
ocorrido principalmente por via sexual e
a detecção precoce continua sendo chave,
OK? para tentar interromper a a
propagação. E qual é a manifestação
clínica? Então, tem vários sintomas, dor
de cabeça, linfonos inchados, que são as
ínguas, erupções cutâneas, né, com
crostas e febre malestar geral.
Então, o diagnóstico é realizado através
de testes laboratoriais, testes
moleculares e sequenciamento genético
que devem ser conduzidos em pacientes
que têm suspeita da doença. As amostras
são coletadas de secreções de lesões ou
quando as lesões secaram das crostas.
OK? Então, como podemos prevenir essa
situação? A principal prevenção eh em
relação à contração do MPOX é evitar
contato direto com casos suspeitos ou
confirmados, usar equipamento de
proteção individual, que é luva,
máscara, isso que o pessoal da área de
saúde, né? aventais, proteção
ocular, isolamento imediato de casos
suspeitos ou confirmados, lavagem
regular das mãos com água e sabão ou uso
de higienizadores à base de álcool,
limpeza e desinfecção adequada
superfícies e objetos contaminados.
Então, para contatos de indivíduos
infectados, precações adicionais, além
de usar os equipamentos de proteção
individual, é a lavagem adequada de
roupa de cama, de toalha, de utensílio,
de itens pessoais, água morna e
detergente. Descarte apropriado de
materiais contaminados. OK?
Vamos falar um pouquinho da vacinação.
Eh, deixando claro para vocês que eu não
estou acompanhando assim muito de perto
essa questão da vacinação. Eu vou
dividir com vocês o que eu pude apurar
sobre isso e se eu tiver mais
informações futuramente eu vou dividir
com
vocês. Tem uma vacina chamada Invanex.
Invanex
imv, também conhecida como Gineos com J.
Gineos, que demonstrou teoricamente 84%
de eficácia contra a infecção por esse
vírus com uma única dose. Segundo o
estudo que foi publicado no The Lens
infectious Diseas, isso em março desse
ano, OK? Então, é bem recente essa
publicação. No entanto, para indivíduos
imunocomprometidos, particularmente
aqueles que têm HIV, duas
doses são necessárias para a
proteção. Essa vacina foi recentemente
aprovada pela Agência Nacional de
Vigilância Sanitária, um Visa, OK? Está
disponível através do Sistema Único de
Saúde, segundo eles. E quanto a
tratamento, atualmente não tem medicação
específica para o MPOX. A Agência
Reguladora de Saúde Brasileira Anvisa
estendeu autorização para o Ministério
da Saúde importar e usar o
Tecovirimate, um medicamento para tratar
doenças por
ortopox vírus, que é essa classe que à
qual pertence o
MPOX. Mas esse medicamento ele é usado
caso a caso, né, geralmente nos casos
graves,
tecovirat, tá? Não conheço nada essa
medicação, vou ter que estudar um pouco
depois sobre
isso. Então, paraa maioria dos pacientes
o tratamento se concentra em manejar os
sintomas, controlar os sintomas,
aliviando a dor, prevenindo infecções
secundárias, tratamentos tópicos das
feridas para elas não infectarem, né, de
maneira secundária e cuidado, suporte
para manter hidratação e nutrição, tá?
Vamos falar um pouco sobre controvérsias
em torno da vacina.
Então, tem várias controvérsias e pontos
de debate que emergeram em relação às
vacinas contra Mipox,
particularmente as vacinas da classe MVA
BN, que é a que eu acabei de falar,
Gineus/INVanex, e também o ACAN 2000,
né? Então, a AC 2000 é uma vacina viva
contra a varíula, então é um vírus vivo
e competente para replicação, né? né?
Então essa vacina ACAN 2000 estaria
associado a um risco mais elevado de
efeitos colaterais graves, incluído
miocardite,
pericardite, vaxínia progressiva,
exczema vacinatum, encefalite e até
mortes em casos raros de pessoas
imunosuprimidas. Então, houve relatos de
indivíduos não vacinados que
desenvolveram doenças graves após o
contato com pessoas recentemente
vacinadas.
devido à eliminação do vírus vacinal do
local da vacinação. Então tem essa
polêmica em torno desse vírus com vus
vivo. OK? Já essa que o Ministério da
Saúde aprovou, né, a Gineos ou
Invanex, ela é considerada uma vacina
mais segura, não replicante, ou seja, o
vírus não se multiplica, OK? Eh, e a
maioria dos efeitos colaterais são
leves, amoderados, dor no local da
injeção, dor de cabeça, dores
musculares, cansaço, mas efeitos
colaterais raros incluem linfadenopatia,
que seria aumento do linfonodo com dor,
né, febre, dor nas circulações em
pessoas com eczema, possíveis
exacerbações e a dados limitados sobre o
uso em crianças e mulheres grávidas
amamentando, né? E eu esqueci de ver
qual que é a tecnologia dessa vacina. Eu
vou checar isso rapidamente para falar
para
vocês. Me de só um instante.
Tá. Vamos ver se vocês estão se
manifestando. A Sandra tá dizendo que o
áudio está excelente. Alice Vog dando
boa noite. Boa noite, Alice. Eloía, boa
noite também. Eh, boa noite,
Miram. Vamos ver aqui
se respondo para vocês com mais
categoria sobre essa vacina.
Bem, essa vacina Gineus ou
Ivanex, tá, ela não é de RNA mensageiro.
A tecnologia dela é baseada numa
plataforma de vírus vivo, atenuado, não
replicante e ele utiliza na plataforma
dela o vírus vacínia Ancara modificado.
É uma cepa altamente atenuada,
enfraquecida do vírus
vacínia. Ele é vivo, mas não consegue se
replicar em células humanas, segundo
consta.
E essa cepa MVA, né, que essa que eu tô
falando aqui é um vírus atenuado, foi
desenvolvido através de múltiplas
passagens, células de fibroblasto de
embrião de galinha, tornando segura e
incapaz de causar doença, segundo
consta. OK?
São duas doses, o intervalo é de 4
semanas, aparentemente. Então, ele
utiliza uma tecnologia convencional, não
tem nada a ver com Ren mensageiro e nem
com modificação genética. OK?
Bem, vamos continuar
aqui. Então, tem essa situação que por
enquanto não tá liberado para criança
nem mulher grávida amamentando. Tem os
efeitos colaterais que já comentamos,
que são dor de cabeça, dor no local de
injeção, dor muscular e cansaço e
raramente linfadenopatia, febre, dor na
articulação e
e sobre a eficácia dessas vacinas contra
mipox, está configurado que pode
diminuir ao longo do tempo e o grau de
proteção pode depender do número de
doses recebidas. Então, alguns estudos
observam que, embora as vacinas gerem
anticorpos adequados, elas não
ofereceriam proteção total contra a
infecção sistêmica e caso infecção
ocorreram tanto indivíduos vacinados
quanto não vacinados.
As vacinas contra a varíula, como a CAN
2000, que é essa que deu mais problema,
que é o vírus não
atenuado, oferece alguma proteção
cruzada contra o Mipox, mas o nível de
proteção e duração permanece em
sudo. E nós sabemos, né, que eu acredito
que por bons motivos, né, vocês conhecem
minha opinião sobre esse assunto, está
acontecendo muita hesitação, né?
hesitação quanto essa nova vacina do
Mipox e influenciada por preocupações
sobre efeitos colaterais, dúvidas sobre
eficácia e informações inconsistentes.
Então, estudos indicam que a disposição
para receber a vacina varia por gênero e
orientação sexual. Mulheres geralmente
são menos dispostas a indivíduos
homossexuais estão mais dispostos porque
eles reconhecem que estão mais em risco,
né?
Existe aí alegações fazendo associações
do surto de MPOX
a OK da COVID, OK? E sugerindo que MPOX
é na
verdade uma outra situação, outro vírus
que seria o vírus do
episóter, que na verdade aparentemente
não procede isso. São vírus diferentes,
OK?
Tem havido também críticas a ênfase
excessiva da vacinação como única
solução e tem tido apelos para abordar
medidas mais amplas de saúde pública e
garantir acesso equitativo às vacinas,
né, que isso não está acontecendo.
Geralmente o a compra dessas vacinas
ainda tá muito limitada.
Então, existe aí planos no Ministério da
Saúde para adquirir
34.560 testes para MPOX nesse ano de
2025. Eh, que se essa situação não
piorar, parece bem razoável esse número
de testes, né?
Então essa iniciativa fortalece a
capacidade diagnóstica do país e pode
permitir o sequenciamento genômico do
vírus que fornece informações essenciais
para entender a evolução e padrões de
transmissão.
E também o país estaria particularmente
atento à situação internacional,
especialmente em relação à variante
clado 1B, que foi detectado em vários
países com aumento notável de casos na
República Democrática do Congo e outras
nações africanas.
Então, embora o Pará tenha registrado
esses 19 casos, né, e duas mortes pelo
MPOX, nos primeiros 4 meses desse ano,
as autoridades sanitárias mantém que não
há surto andamento no estado e os casos
parecem ser isolados, não tem uma CAD
estabelecida de
transmissão. Eh, porém, essa morte de
uma figura pública chamou atenção aí da
comunidade. E esse assunto voltou à
Volga que tinha uns dois anos que o
pessoal não estava falando muito disso.
Daí uma situação destaca a importância
de vigilância contínua, detectação
precoce e educação pública contra as
medidas sobre medidas
preventivas. Beleza, pessoal? Então,
vamos às perguntas da live. Alguém tem
pergunta agora ao vivo sobre essa
questão aí do MBOX?
Aparentemente não. Se tiver depois vocês
falam, tá? Então vamos responder as
dúvidas. Deixa eu ver se tá bem visível
isso
aqui. Tá bem visível, né? Primeira
pergunta da Maria Helena sobre portes de
nata de leite preparados pela indústria
contém as mesmas quantidades de
contaminação do leite. Teria algo mais
para me ensinar sobre nata do leite?
Vamos lá então falar sobre
nata, tá? Primeiro, o que que é a nata?
Pelo menos um contexto industrializado,
é o o produto obtido pela centrifugação
do leite para separar a fração rica em
gordura, seguida de tratamentos térmicos
com pausterização, né, ou UHT, né, que
também é um processo de alta
temperatura.
e a contaminação da nata estaria
diretamente relacionada à do leite de
origem. OK? Então, quais são os
possíveis contaminantes químicos da
nata?
Como existem aí compostos lipossolúveis
que podem diluir no leite, que vem do
meio ambiente e são tóxicos, que é o
caso de
dioxinas,
PCBs, já falei disso em lives no canal
anteriormente, dioxina, PCB, pesticida,
micotoxina, que são toxinas de fungo,
especialmente a aflatoxina M1.
Eles, como são liposolúbres, tendem a se
concentrar na fração gordurosa do leite,
né? Como a nata é muito mais rica em
gordura que o leite, esses contaminantes
geralmente aparecem com situações mais
altas na nata, em derivados como a
manteiga, ok? Então, por exemplo, a
aflatxina M1 de grande preocupação
toxicológica é encontrada tanto no leite
quanto na nata, muitas vezes em níveis
mais elevados na nata devido à
concentrações de gordura. OK? Também
podemos ter microbió eh perdão,
contaminantes microbiológicos. Então, a
pausterização e o tratamento
UHT reduzem de forma significativa a
carga microbiana, tanto no leite quanto
na nata, mas não eliminam totalmente o
risco, especialmente se houver falhas na
higiene ou contaminação pós
processamento. Então, a gordura pode
proteger algumas bactérias durante o
aquecimento. Por isso, a posterização da
nat costuma ser feita em temperaturas um
pouco mais altas do que a do leite. E
tem estudos mostrando que a nata
industrializada apresenta menor
incidência de contaminação microbiana em
comparação com nata artesanal, porém
ainda pode haver presença de coliformes
e raramente patógenos como
estafilococosuros queixa colhe se houver
falhas no
processo. Falando um pouquinho sobre
perfil nutricional da nata, como é uma
fração rica em gordura. ela vai ter mais
vitaminas liposolúveis, é o caso da
vitamina A, que é de duas a 12 vezes
mais alta na nata do que no leite
integral. Já comentei sobre isso, mas na
pasterização é feita em temperaturas
mais altas quando é a nata, porque
existe um risco maior de proteção
bacteriana conferida pela gordura.
Então, no leite não homogeneizado,
quando você faz a preparação da nata em
casa, ela vai se separar
naturalmente. Mas na indústria esse
processo é feito por centrifugação, né,
que fica
girando. E a nata é utilizada em
culinária, em confeitaria, em produção
de manteiga, de cremes e sobremesas.
OK, então é só o
ponto. Vamos pra próxima
pergunta. Maria Helena tá ao
vivo? Não sei. Acho que não. Próxima
pergunta. Você falou na live passada que
nem todo diabético poderia tomar
verberina. Por quê? É a pergunta do
Antônio Renato que está ao vivo. Bem,
Antônio, eu não falei exatamente isso.
OK. O que eu quis dizer é
que
diabéticos que não estão fazendo
dieta e estão confiando na beberina para
resolver o problema, muitas vezes não é
o caso, tá?
E também dependendo do tipo de
medicamento que esse diabético tiver
tomando, às vezes não é interessante
associar a beberina, tá? Explico, né? A
beberina é um ótimo hipoglicemiante. Ele
pode ser utilizado junto com a
mediformina na maioria dos casos, mas em
alguns casos ele pode potencializar a
ação de alguns outros medicamentos
antidiabéticos de uma maneira ao
aumentar o risco de hipoglicemia. Mas
isso para mim não é um problema tão
sério, porque se essa pessoa já tem
nessa situação de tá correndo o risco de
hipoglicemia, é
porque ela geralmente precisa baixar a
dose dos medicamentos,
ok? Então existe essa potencialização,
existe essa possibilidade de interação
da beberina com metiformina, que apesar
da prática eu não vejo acontecer isso, e
mesmo com sulfonil ureas, aí eu acho que
o risco maior é o uso associado à
insulina, tá? Então tem que ficar muito
atento se você usar beberina junto com a
insulina. Idosos são mais suscetíveis e
mais sensíveis a variações bruscas de
glicose.
Tá? Então a beberina às vezes tem uma
interação ruim com outros
fármacos. Já aconteceu de paciente meu
que tava tomando remédio para pressão
arterial, teve interação com beberina,
né? Isso gerou uma situação aí que a
pessoa passou mal, né? Então a pressão
caiu muito porque houve alteração do
metabolismo dessa droga com a beberina,
ok? Então tem que tomar cuidado, tem que
começar com doses baixas e verificar
como é que fica a
situação. A beberina por si só pode
causar efeitos adversos, né? efeitos
colaterais como náuses, constipação,
diarreia, dor abdominal, refluxo e pode
ser mais problemático com a situação em
pessoas com histórico de distúrbios
digestivos ou constipação crônica, né?
Mais comum é dar diarré e gases do que
dar necessariamente constipação, tá? Mas
pode acontecer um ou outro.
E como sempre, a beberina não é
recomendada para gestante, para
lactante, para criança, pessoas que têm
insuficiência hepática, hipotensão ou
deficiência de enzima G6 PD,
tá? Então, recapitulando, a Bebelina é
excelente opção para controlar tanto a
glicose do sangue quanto baixar a
triglice. É muito bom também.
é uma ótima opção para tratamento
coaduvante do diabetes tipo
2, porém temos que avaliar caso a caso,
tá? O perfil clínico individual
importante, a presença de outras
comorbidades, o risco de interações,
como eu falei, e também deve ser feito
acompanhamento regular dos níveis
glicêmicos. Não é todo diabético, então,
que pode usar a berberina de forma
livre. existe algum risco de
hipoglicemia que obviamente vai ser
muito maior naqueles diabéticos que já
conseguiram controlar bem com a
dieta. Existe o risco de interação com
antihipertensivos e outros medicamentos
com
anticoagulantes. Então exige
monitoramento contínuo dos
médicos. Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Se você quiser perguntar, Antônio, você
tá ao vivo aí, né? Perguntar se você
entendeu a
explicação. Vi uma reportagem que
influencer pegou bactéria estafococos
após o unhas e essa bactéria foi para o
coração e teve que fazer cirurgia grave
e as
pessoas e as pressas, mas se curou
graças a Deus. Sua opinião, por favor,
dos perigos da
bactéria. Bem, eu não fiquei sabendo
muito bem sobre
essa situação que você tá falando aí,
tá? Mas vamos falar sobre
estaflococusalos. é uma bactéria muito
comum na pele, geralmente também ela tá
presente debaixo das
unhas, em pessoas imunocompetentes, ou
seja, que tá com sistema imune OK, ela
geralmente pode causar infecções leves.
Geralmente ela não dá nada mais grave do
que um furúnculo ou inflamações, né,
paroníquias, né, inflamações ao redor
das unhas, mas em alguns casos mais
raros pode se tornar
perigosa caso entre na corrente
sanguínea. Obviamente que se ela correr
pelo sangue, ela pode atingir órgãos
distantes, pode atingir o coração
causando endocardite, né, que é uma
inflamação das válvulas cardíacas.
E essa infecção das válvulas cardíacas
pode até exigir futuramente o uso
de eh próteses de válvula, né? Pode ter
que fazer uma cirurgia muito invasiva e
ter que fazer
esse replacement, né? Ou seja, reposição
de
válvula. Em casos graves também isso
gera insuficiência cardíaca, né? esse
problema nas válvulas cardíacas e pode
ter que exigir uma cirurgia. Talvez a
cirurgia de emergência, não sei detalhes
desse caso, tenha sido eh por conta de
suficiência volvar, né? Não sei se foi o
caso, mas vamos falar um pouquinho sobre
ruer
unhas. Então, se você r unhas com muita
frequência, isso pode se tornar uma
porta de entrada para infecções, porque
o ato de rolar a unha pode causar
pequenas lesões na pele ao redor das
unhas. Isso pode facilitar a entrar de
bactérias, como é o caso da
flococos. Então, como eu já disse,
debaixo das unhas tem grande
concentração desses microorganismos.
O eunhas pode transferir esses
patógenos, esses bichos paraa boca e
pode também introduzi-los na corrente
sanguínea, mesmo através da ferida do
dedo ou através da boca. Ã, quando é
infecção local na unha, pode ser uma
paroníquia, né? E se houver aí uma
imunossupressão, o sistema imune dessa
pessoa tá ruim, essa infecção pode
viajar pelo sangue, levando infecções
sistêmicas.
Então é raro isso aconteceu, por isso
que virou notícia, a maioria das
infecções são leves e quando acontecem
pessoas imunosuprimidas, as bactérias
podem entrar na corrente sanguínea e
atingir órgãos vitais, como eu falei,
coração, causando hocardite, que é uma
infecção grave do coração.
Ro unhas também tá associado a problemas
dentários, danos aos dentes e gingivite,
problemas digestórios por causa da
ingestão de patógenos, de doenças e
impactos psicológicos,
tá? Então esse é o caso aí, tá? Isso
virou notícia porque é raro, mas é um
sinal de alerta para as pessoas evitarem
de ruer
unha. Se uma mulher tem diabetes de 200
e não se cuida, quais seriam os
perigos? Bem, existe uma série de
riscos, tanto a curto quanto a longo
prazo. Complicações de curto prazo seria
cetoacidose diabética.
que altos níveis de glicose pode levar a
cetacidose. Não é a mesma acidose leve
metabólica que você faz com jejum ou com
a dieta cetogênica, é outro tipo de
cetooacidose, tá? E leva a um acúmulo de
ácidos no sangue e pode ser fatal se não
for tratado de forma rápida. OK? Outra
complicação é a síndrome hiperglicêmica
hiperosmolar, tá? quando a glicose tá
muito muito alta no sangue, isso é mais
comum em idosos, que pode causar
desidratação severa e alterações
neurológicas. E em relação aos mais
comuns, que são as complicações
crônicas, ou seja, de instalação lenta e
progressiva ao longo do tempo, existe
complicações vasculares, né? o risco do
infarto do miocárdio, o risco de
acidente vascular cerebral
isquêmico que é significativamente maior
em
diabéticos e isso aumenta muito após a
menopausa em
mulheres. Pode também acontecer doença
renal crônica, que diabetes é uma grande
causa física renal crônica. Isso leva a
necessidade às vezes de diálise e até de
transplante renal. Existe também a
retinopatia diabética, que é a doença da
retina, por danos aos vasos sanguíneos,
por excesso de açúcar, levando a perda
progressiva da visão e até cegueira. E
tem também a neuropatia diabética, que é
muito comum, que acontece nas etmidades,
especialmente membros inferiores, devido
ao dano aos nervos e também dano aos
vasos periféricos desses membros
inferiores, que leva a dor, leva a
formigamento, perda de sensibilidade e
risco aumentado de feridas que podem não
cicatrizar e que geralmente não dói,
porque o diabético tem baixa
sensibilidade e isso pode levar até
amputações. OK? Então, a má circulação,
que eu já comentei, e a neuropatia
aumenta o risco de que essas feridas de
difícil cicatrização vão piorando,
levando a úlceras grandes, infecções e
amputações. E pessoas diabéticas também,
especialmente mulheres,
torceptibilidade a infecções,
especialmente infecções urinárias e
ginecológicas, tá? É bem comum tanto
infecção urinária quanto candidíase
vaginal de
repetição e em alguns casos pode evoluir
até para sepsica, a infecção
generalizada.
E além disso, o diabetes pode causar
irregularidades menstruais, pode causar
disfunção sexual, pode causar
dificuldade para engravidar em mulheres
mais jovens, pode dar uma gestação de
risco essa mulher engravite, causando o
diabetes da gestação, né, o diabetes
gestacional e também aumentar o risco de
aumento de pressão arterial durante a
gravidez, que é a pré-eclâmpsia, né, ou
doença hipertensiva. específica da
gravidez. O DG aumenta o risco de aborto
de infecções durante a gravidez,
malformações também para o bebê, além de
prematuridade e alguns casos mais graves
até óbito do bebê. Em relação ao saúde
mental, mulheres diabéticas têm maior
risco de depressão, risco dobrado de
depressão, que pode dificultar o
autocuidado e o controle do açúcar.
Então, existe um risco aumentado de
morte precoce em mulheres diabéticas.
Mulheres com diabetes t até 60% mais
riscos de morte prematura do que pessoas
sem a
doença. Então tem que ficar muito atento
em relação a isso. Então, resumindo,
doença cardiovascular como infarto AVC
isquêmico insuficiência cardíaca,
insuficiência renal com perda da função
do órgão e necessidade de transplante,
perda de da visão por lesão à retina,
neuropatia periférica, alterações
vasculares periféricas, risco de lesões
graves e
amputações, infecções de repetição,
tanto ginecológicas quanto urinárias,
alterações ações de saúde mental com
aumento de depressão e aumento de
mortalidade precoce.
Beleza? Deixa eu ver se nesse intervalo
chegou mais perguntas
aqui. Opa, tem mais perguntas aqui. Tem
mais perguntas
aqui. Ah, tem a pergunta do Antônio
sobre a live. Pera aí que eu
vou O que que você achou do trabalho do
professor Alexandre Costa? Dei uma
olhada, tá, no trabalho dele. Achei bem
parecido com o professor Luís Antônio
Peixoto do
Vale. Eu vi que ele fala muito sobreva
Mundial, que ele fala bastante sobre Big
Farma, ele fala bastante sobre
manipulações aí globais
para escravidão dos povos, né, de
supressão do livre
arbítrio. Então eu gostei do trabalho
dele, sim. e eu vou procurar entrar em
contato com ele e vou pensar seriamente
nessa live. Sim. Tá bom. Agora a gente
tem mais perguntas que entraram depois,
entraram agora durante a live, tá? Esse
aqui eu não sei se eu vou conseguir
mostrar. Deixa eu ver se eu consigo
mostrar. Eu acho que consigo sim. Vou
pedir um minuto para vocês aqui para
criar rapidamente a estrutura, tá?
Dá só um minutinho que eu vou criar aqui
só apresentação das próximas perguntas
aqui para ficar mais fácil de vocês
visualizarem. Já estamos aí com 40
minutos de
live.Quanto tá criando as novas
perguntas aí.
Ver se já criou o site aqui. Não tá
fazendo edições
ainda. Pera aí que eu vou ter que
atualizar esse essa
apresentação. OK. Vamos ver se a
gente tá aqui. Já atualizou aqui. Ah,
vamos publicar.
Copiar. OK. P.
Uai, por que que não apareceu aqui? Pera
aí.
Pronto. Ver se tá dividindo a tela com
vocês
aqui. Próxima
[Música]
pergunta aqui do
autismo. A próxima pergunta que
colocaram aqui?
H, então
pergunta. Existe pessoas que ao se
deparar com TDH e autismo tendem a
atribuir a pessoas com essas doenças um
certo nível de inteligência, mas na
prática vemos que a maioria das pessoas,
exceto algumas pessoas com essas doenças
têm uma baixa qualidade de vida.
Qual sua opinião como um pai acha que as
pessoas deveriam olhar mais para a
realidade e assim tentar buscar cura ou
continuar com essa mentalidade? Então é
uma coisa que me incomoda bastante, viu?
Quando eu falei desse
assunto uma vez num vídeo uns anos atrás
que eu falei do meu filho e quando eu
disse que meu filho tinha uma forma
de grau de cuidados,
né, grau um, né, uma forma leve, o
pessoal ficou meio chocado porque eu
falei que ele tinha um autismo leve,
graças a Deus. O pessoal que tem filho
com autismo moderado e severo se
sentiu ofendido quando eu comentei isso.
E isso na época me chamou muita atenção,
né? Porque existe essa eh ideia assim de
romantizada, né, de que o autismo são
crianças cristais, são crianças
evoluídas, são crianças na nova era por
aí vai, né? E eu acho que isso pode ser,
por um lado, um alívio pros pais que têm
essa situação tão sofrida dentro de
casa, mas por outro lado pode ser uma
maneira de se autoiludir,
né? E o pessoal sempre gosta de usar a
exceção como regra, né? Porque tem os
savantes que tem que tem o o pessoal que
tem a forma de Deia de
Tea,
como também o o tem o Savan que tem que
eles são meio gênios em algumas áreas. E
tem também o o me fugiu agora o
nome o daqui a pouco eu lembro. Enfim.
Tá. Mas, mas então existe na mídia, em
algumas comunidades, essa necessidade de
associar o TDAH e o autismo a
inteligência elevada, nível criatividade
elevado, talentos
especiais. Existem pessoas que têm essas
situações, como eu falei, como Savan,
como Astinger, lembrei agora, o Savã e o
Astinger. Essa é a exceção, não é a
regra,
tá? Apenas uma minoria dos autistas tem
habilidades extraordinárias, tá? A
maioria enfrenta dificuldade social.
dificuldade de comunicação. Meu filho
agora que tá na adolescência, ele tá com
muita confusão
mental. A gente tá tendo que ter muito
cuidado com ele. Muitas vezes ele não
sabe nem expressar o que ele tá
sentindo, né? Isso porque ele é uma
forma leve, né? Pessoas também com TDH
podem ser muito inteligentes, tá? Mas
muitas delas têm problemas de
organização, de foco, podem ser
impulsivas, podem ter problema de
regulação emocional que vai prejudicar
desempenho acadêmico, desempenho
profissional, programas de relações
pessoais, né, relações de
trabalho. Muitos estudos mostram que TDH
e o autismo estão associados à qualidade
de vida mais baixa. Isso não tem a ver
necessariamente com QI por causa de
dificuldade de socialização, dificuldade
de construção de relações, risco maior
de ansiedade,
depressão, transtornos mentais,
problemas acadêmicos, problemas
profissionais, estresse familiar,
estresse conjugal, sobrecarga de
cuidadores,
né? Então, a gente tem que tentar
balançar eh o realismo com a compaixão,
né? O pessoal que fica eh romantizando
essas doenças, a gente tem que ter
compressão, tem que ter carinho, tem que
ter afeto e não tá atirando na na cara
das pessoas o problema, né? Quando eu
fiz essa live, comentei que meu filho
tinha uma fama leve, graças a Deus, eu
não tava atacando de forma nenhuma
outros pais que têm essa situação. Mas
na nossa sociedade hoje, que
tá eh muito na base do vitimismo, né, é
muito complicado hoje você falar
qualquer coisa, porque existe
essa esse estímulo ao vitimismo, né? E
as
pessoas eh muitas vezes começam a
fantasiar em cima disso.
Daí então a gente tem que tentar
balançar a compaixão, a ética, com essa
percepção eh apurada do que tá
acontecendo com essa esse estímulo ao
vitimismo. OK?
E a gente tem que também evitar de
romantizar esses casos raros de gênios
autistas ou pessoas que tm TDH que
seriam
superotadas, porque isso pode piorar a
situação paraa maioria das pessoas. tem
que evitar essa banalização que tá
acontecendo. Outro dia eu vi lá que o
não acompanho o material dele, não sei
se ele tá sendo correto no que ele tá
afirmando, mas o
Nutritom, isso eu só fiquei sabendo
através da Ana Paula que me falou que o
Nutritonton estaria se decalarando ao
mesmo tempo autista e ao mesmo tempo
TDH, tá? Eh, eu posso tá errado. Não
conheço bem o
Nutritontom, porém a chance disso ser
verdade, eu acho que é tipo
2,1%, tá? Eh, eu acho que ele tá sendo
um pouco incorreto nessa abordagem que
ele tá fazendo, tá tentando conseguir
holofotes, tá? Posso estar enganado, tá,
pessoal? Então, vocês me perdoem se
vocês têm informações aí super claras
que o do Tritonton não é TDAH e autista.
E quando a gente banaliza essa doença,
tá, e começa a achar que todo mundo é
altíssimo, todo mundo é TDAH, a gente
cria um dano muito grande nas reais
vítimas do problema, né? A gente pode
realmente causar uma reação da sociedade
achando que é frescura, que é invenção e
isso prejudicar muito realmente as
pessoas que têm problemas em relação a
isso,
né? Então a gente tem que tentar aqui se
equilibrar na corda banda.
eh tentando aí balancear a esperança,
balancear essa essas atitudes aí um
pouco
fantasiosas com uma abordagem prática e
realista sobre esse problema, certo?
para poder melhorar a qualidade de vida
dessas pessoas, respeitando
individualidades. Lembrando que por trás
do diagnóstico tem um indivíduo com as
suas particularidades. O indivíduo não é
definido pela doença. Lembrar que cada
pessoa tem as suas necessidades
individuais que não devem ser enxergados
como estereótipos. OK? Eu acho que deu
para
abordar de maneira bem completa essa
questão aí. Tá
bom. Próxima
pergunta. Deixa eu ver se eu consigo pôr
na tela.
Ã, Dr. Alan, essa doença, nova doença
de, estão falando do MPOX, né? Não seria
gerado pelas
[Música]
picadinhas. Essa pergunta não é a
mesma. Deixa eu ver se eu pulei alguma
pergunta
aqui. Minutinho só. Ah, tá. Eu pulei
sim. Mas por que que não apareceu aqui?
Pera aí. Pergunta anterior. Tá, não
apareceu. Não sei por. Tá, acho que
pulou aqui. Mas a próxima pergunta seria
o seguinte.
Essa nova doença, tá falando, eu acho da
MPOX, não seria gerada
pelas injeções. Será que não é só em
pessoas que sofreram as
injeções? Já pensou nessa
possibilidade? Pensar na possibilidade
eu já pensei, tá? Mas eh não é o que me
parece baseado no meu conhecimento e
baseado no bom senso, tá, pessoal? A
gente pode tem que tomar
cuidado
porque a gente pode ceder aí alguns
exageros que estão acontecendo, tá?
Na sua opinião, uma pessoa que tomou a
última dose da injeção em
2014, por que 2014 da hepatite eh
B1 RNA mensageiro, que quer dizer
calchante.
Bem, talvez tá falando 2024, não tô
entendendo direito isso aqui. O que que
seria a injeção composta num cartão de
vacina em 2013? Tem RNA mensageiro?
Olha, não tem, porque nesse ano de 2014,
se você não errou aí na agitação, não
tem essa essa vacina aí de RNA, não, né?
Porque em
2014 não existia essa tecnologia de
herné
mensageiro. Essa
tecnologia que se utilizava até 2020 era
de proteínas recombinantes do antígeno
de superfície do hepatite B, tá? Não
tinha nada de RNA mensageiro aí, né?
Isso era produzido em levedura.
E as primeiras vacinas aí de RNA
mensageiro para hepatite B são começaram
a ser testadas em
2022. Então eu não sei se você tem mais
informações sobre esse assunto, me fale,
tá? Mas eu não sei porque que você
chegou a essa conclusão que em 2014 já
existiu eh essa tecnologia aí de RNA
mensageiro. Talvez você tenha uma
informação aí que eu não tô com acesso
no
momento. Bem, vamos para a próxima aqui.
Quais o período os perigos da
metiformina com a dose segura, tá?
Genérico original. Qual é melhor?
Então vamos falar
então
sobre os efeitos colaterais da
metformmina. Tanto a metformina quanto o
glifá, né, que é o nome comercial mais
comum, né, eles têm basicamente aí os
mesmos efeitos colaterais. não não
existiria essa necessidade aí
de distinguir um do outro,
tá? Os efeitos mais comuns é diarreia,
constipação, náusea, eh gases e perdas
de apetite, tá? E geralmente começam no
início do tratamento e depois vão
melhorando. Outro efeito muito comum é a
deficiência de B12, tá? A mediformina
pode atrapalhar a absorção de B12. Então
eu tem que ficar muito atento quanto a
isso. Existe um risco
muito leve e raro de
hipoglicemia quando você usa
metifformina de forma isolada. E uma
crise aí de acidose láctica é muito rara
que é caracterizada pelo acúmulo de
ácido láctico no sangue, ok? A dose que
se usa de 500
mg até três vezes ao
dia. Então essa que é a faixa de
dose. Existe também uma forma de
liberação prolongada de 2000 mg, ou
seja, 2 g ao dia. Então, a dose máxima
poderia chegar até
2,5 g, mas geralmente o pessoal não
passa de 1,5 g pro dia, tá
bom? E até onde eu sei, o genérico e o
original não tem muita
diferença. Bem, vamos pra próxima
pergunta.
Não, parece que esse foi a última. Deixa
eu ver se tem mais alguma
aqui. Ah, não tem mais uma aqui. Mas
esse aqui não vou colocar na tela, não,
tá? Se a gente vai perder tempo aqui.
Dout. Alan, você falou que tem um outro
lado além da medicina integrativa que é
a tecnologia. Então, acho
pertinente perguntar qual a sua opinião
sobre Bitcoin. Você investe? É seguro,
acha que tem futuro? Eu particularmente
não sou muito fã. Ah, tá. Obrigado pela
pergunta. Eu acompanho Bitcoin há muito
tempo, mas não acompanho no sentido de
ser especialista em Bitcoin, tá? Mas
sim,
porque é uma coisa que é da tecnologia.
Eu gosto muito de tecnologia já há
muitos anos, né? Mas eu nunca tive
coragem de investir em Bitcoin, tá? Eh,
e vou te dizer por quê. Eu acho que o
Bitcoin é um conceito
muito complicado, né, de você
colocar poder computacional a serviço de
um algoritmo para gerar um
código. E esse código ele tenta imitar
uma escassez que acontece na
natureza e
isso por uma convenção humana ser
considerada uma coisa de valor, tá? Eu
tenho muita dificuldade de aceitar o
conceito primordial essencial do
Bitcoin, porque eu entendo que esse
conceito de escassez gerado por
algoritmos computacionais é uma
coisa extremamente artificial, tá? E
essa é uma coisa também extremamente
manipulável, tá? No meu ponto de vista,
o pessoal que divul divulga o Bitcoin,
eles falam muito em liberdade, falta de
controle dos governos, tá? Mas eu não
caio muito nessa conversa. Eu acho que
eh é muito temeroso, tá? O meu feeling,
tá?
é que essa tecnologia, apesar de ser
blockchain, uma tecnologia muito segura,
que não pode ser
hackeada até o momento, apesar de que
eles estão tentando criar tecnologias de
computadores quânticos para quebrar aí
as tecnologias de segurança, né, de de
criptografia, eu acho que vai chegar em
algum momento que vai ser quebrado essas
essas as seguranças aí do do
blockchain. Então é assim, eu tenho esse
feeling, por conta desse feeling, eu
nunca investi em Bitcoin, tá? Eu acho
que é um mercado extremamente instável.
O meu irmão, por acaso, trabalha, aliás,
trabalhou, né? Ele já saiu da empresa,
ele trabalhou uns dois anos numa empresa
de Bitcoin.
E a a orientação mesmo para quem
e é investidor é que coloque no máximo
5% do patrimônio em Bitcoin, tá? Então
eu não recomendo investimento em Bitcoin
e eu particularmente não gosto de
Bitcoin, tá? Espero que tenha ficado
claro aí meu posicionamento. Oem.
Tá bom, eu tô terminando a live
aqui. Vamos uma pergunta ao vivo
aqui. Eh, Dr. Alan, aquelas vacinas que
tomamos e demos aos filhos há décadas
atrás ainda são eficientes para proteção
e prevenção? Sim, mas existe teorias da
conspiração, entre aspas, aí dizendo que
elas poderiam estar já contaminadas com
na mensageiro. Ou já estaria essa cepa
de vírus fora da cobertura das vacinas?
Não tá em cobertura. Sim. Tá. O que se
discute aí nos círculos é que poderia
ter já uma
contaminação
eh com René mensageiro nessas vacinas
que eu não tenho essa confirmação. E eu
também recebi um material aí de uma
seguidora minha eh falando que já existe
uma vacina de RNA
mensageiro nos Estados Unidos para
porcos, para uma diarreia lá dos porcos
que é viral e que estaria já
contaminando essa vacina RNA. estaria
contaminando já a cadeia alimentar
naquele
país. E sinceramente eu não tive ainda
nenhum artigo que eu tenha ficado com
certeza ciente de que exista o shed, né,
que é aquela situação de espalhar as
partículas de RNA mensageiro através de
contato, beijo, secreção, alimentação,
etc. Então, sinceramente, espero que não
aconteça o sheding, porque se o sheding
for real, isso vai ser muito, muito
problemático, essa questão aí da
vacinação dos porcos americanos que vão
chegar uma hora ou outra no Brasil, né,
essa situação aí, tá, pessoal? Pessoal,
vamos encerrar a live de hoje. Então, eu
agradeço a participação de vocês, OK? Eu
não sei se colocaram mais, não, não
colocaram mais nenhuma pergunta aqui no
documento não. E vamos nos falando e até
semana que vem, tá? Um abraço no coração
de
vocês. Até a próxima. Tudo de
bom. Eu não.